Prudence means being sensible,
thinking carefully through what will this mean for the community?
What will it mean for them? The next generation?
So what the West has really done is Rob its children and his grandchildren are
the things that we've taken for granted.
I'm Dave Rubin, and this is the Rubin report. As long as you're here,
don't forget to click that little subscribe button and tap that bell over there
so that you actually see our video is crazy. I know. All right,
joining me today is the former deputy prime minister of Australia,
a relentless fighter for freedom and the host of conversations with
John John Anderson. Welcome to the Rubin report.
I am very happy to have you here because I'll start by saying that something
that I'd never have told you in person, even though we've met a couple of times,
you reached out to me about three years ago, right?
When we built this studio and the show was taken off,
there was a nice little bump in what we were doing.
And you reached out to me or your people reached out to me and said,
John Anderson,
former deputy prime minister of Australia would like to chat with you.
He's coming to LA. And it was really the first time that I thought,
Whoa, this thing is seriously international.
That the conversations that I'm having are seriously important.
And we had a great breakfast where we talked about freedom and conversation and
all of those things. And since we've done a couple events together, um,
so I guess my first question is you've been in this fight for a long
time.
When did you start becoming aware that there was something worldwide around
having decent conversations that was sort of becoming the new way of going about
discourse? Well, he might.
My initial sort of concerns around freedom were largely economic.
So I was part of a coalition government in Australia from,
uh, 1996 to 2007.
And we were a reforming government.
Our emphasis on freedom was economic freedom so that we would not pass on debt
burdens and lack of opportunities to young people. And that was my focus.
I think for me,
it was after the great financial crisis and you saw the blame
game started to really play out.
And I started to see that we needed to make major adjustments
to the way we ran our economies in the West.
They're all hopelessly indebted with the exception of a few places like
Australia. Um, but we wouldn't do it. We wouldn't own what we'd done.
And you started to see the shouting become very shrill.
Now it hadn't started then,
but you asked when I started to realize this is a real problem.
It was about that point because I started to see that that actually understood
properly in democracies, governments,
downstream of culture and socioeconomics and the whole,
um, Lehman brothers collapsed was about, uh, collapsing standards. But again,
you didn't have a grappling with what had gone on in terms of the ethics of it,
bankers, instead of saying, what should I do?
How should I behave rather than what can I get away with?
How can I build a bigger bundle for me? Uh,
and for those around me and hang, you know,
the people who bank with us and have trusted in us and rely on us. I thought,
and I started to think this is getting really serious,
but then it was the nature of the debate because it wasn't a debate anymore.
Now you can't get good public policy without a good debate,
and you can't have a good debate without a reasonable degree of respect for the
other person's dignity and standing.
So it's interesting because I was a struggling standup when Lehman brothers
crash. And I used to work at a comedy club handing out tickets in time square,
right on the corner. I think it was, it was either 50th or 51st and Broadway.
That's where the Lehman brother building wasn't it was this huge lit up,
you know, massive digital display building. And I remember when it,
when it went down, it seems like another lifetime ago,
but what's it like to be one of the guys going, Hey, everybody, we're,
we're about to go off a cliff here. I mean, that's,
that's not what politicians want to do.
They want to always give everybody all the things that.
That was part of the problem. Yeah. Yeah. There is no doubt.
We need to understand that a lot of this rot started in the 1960s.
We gave up talking about, you know, the big sort of, uh, uh, meta narratives.
You know, who am I? What am I, where do I fit? How does the world work?
It's all too hard.
And you can understand that in a way we'd seen horrific Wars would say in the
great depression let's live for us now. And in an age of cheap credit,
we started to rack up debt right across the Western world.
And now it's not as if I'm singling out one country, your country or my country,
we're all in, we've all done it.
And here's the rub in a democracy. So you can say to Mr. Congressman,
um, now, listen, I'll give you my vote. If you promise me X, Y, or Z, and Mr.
Congressman might know instinctively.
If he knows the stuff you want to have many of them,
but shouldn't single out American Congress and a lot of politicians, no,
as much as they should. Yeah. They might refer on us. I look,
and that is not a good way to do it. We can't afford it.
It'll come against your children and your grandchildren.
Unfunded liabilities have pretended to be a nightmare, but we said, not now,
you don't get to have that. All right,
I'll give it to you because it's on the never, never,
and Kings from of old have known that until the credit runs out,
you can live pretty well. But when the credit does run out,
it's a very different story. So it really,
I think it has this Genesis in the sixties and this idea that it's all about me.
Um, I will do what I like with my life, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
We abandoned the golden rule. Do unto others as you'd have them do unto you.
It's all about me now because most people don't live like that.
But that became the sort of prevailing ethos, right?
We live like that in our own lives, right? I mean, sometimes you do.
Or most of us have been in debt at some point or racked up too much credit card
stuff or whatever it is, but you would never just, well, you can't. I mean,
that's the thing as a, as an individual,
you can keep just getting more credit as you keep not paying things,
but somehow in governments, we seem to be able to do that.
Well, I think that, you know, it takes two to tango. I think the electorate,
the voters, if you like have demanded too much,
but politicians so should have known better right across the West have not been
prudent enough either. And there's an old fashioned word called prudence.
It was a classic virtue,
went along with integrity and courage and all of those other ones and prudence
disappeared.
And the story of Lehman brothers in many ways is the disappearance of prudence.
Prudence means being sensible,
thinking carefully through what will this mean for the community?
What will it mean for the next generation?
So what the West has really done is Rob his children and his grandchildren and
the things that we've taken for granted. And, and, and look,
I don't know what privilege is because you can adjust it a thousand ways.
But as I understand it, I think you and I would buy side. We're very,
very fortunate people we've grown up in free society. We've never really wanted,
um, uh, and, and so forth. But those things should never be taken for granted.
Do you see a direct connection then between a stop,
no longer asking the big questions in the sixties to then directly to, well,
politicians then just say, here's more, here's more, here's more,
here's more because,
because the people no longer have the tools to understand why that's actually
not good. That actually really explains what's happening here in America. Yeah.
Yeah. Well,
I do think that I really do think that I think we are paying a terrible price as
my personal view for washing out. You see, I think for a long time,
I don't think in, particularly in my country was ever particularly religious,
but there was an idea that broadly speaking,
the Christian view of the world love your neighbor.
You're accountable to a higher authority. You may dislike your neighbor,
but they still have value and worth and dignity.
And I have to respect that broadly seen as true.
Then it just became seen as one of many truths. Now,
of course we know there's open hostility to, uh, traditional,
uh, underlying beliefs in the West on the part of,
I don't know what you call them.
You call them a lot of the intelligency or the politically correct,
or the people who have the microphones or the elites,
whatever word you want to use.
There's enormous hostility there that says the stuff's dangerous and you
shouldn't expose your children to it, but what's a substitute.
What are we putting up in stead the audio of radical autonomy? I might,
I will hazard a guess that you would understand exactly what I mean.
If I said to you, I don't think you've ever find yourself in yourself.
You actually find yourself by relating to and serving others
and being considerate.
And in looking to see where you can make a difference,
not just for yourself all the time, self-centeredness just destroy.
Well, that's the, I guess,
real irony of the situation as we've removed some of these traditional beliefs,
we've replaced them with authoritarian movements.
They don't seem to be replaced by freer movements.
If there was something so wrong with them, you would think, all right,
well then freedom will replace them. But no,
it seems to always go the other way.
Well, very much so. I mean, I'm a great believer in the, in the freedoms.
I don't think you can never run them unbundled.
And we've had a debate in Australia. What's the first freedom and people say,
well, obviously it's freedom of speech. I save it.
Cause that's the one by which you defend all the other freedoms.
But I think I want to join with Frank for Rudy, you know? And, and,
and that's an interesting story in itself. I would be seen as broadly speaking,
classic liberal Stripe conservative. He would not, you know,
he was a student radical in the sixties. Wonderful and delightful man,
if you've not had him on getting Frank Rudy Kent university. Uh,
but he would say, if I said to him, I did, I said to him,
do you think freedom of speech is the first freedom? He said, no, no, no, no.
You said,
you should understand with your Christian convictions that actually it was
freedom of conscience.
Our forebears were burning one another at the stake and my dreadful,
cruel appalling thing to do to another human being because I had a minority
view. And after a while, people sort of said, well,
this isn't very consistent with Christian charity and it's pretty barbaric
and a stupid because the person with a minority view,
the day that we burned at the stake may in fact be part of a movement that
tomorrow, do you spend the majority,
do you sense that sort of where we're heading right now?
And it really worries me. There's a, there's an aura of triumph.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.